[Musique]
c'est les ultra-riches pour financer les
retraites parmi tous les contre-projets
c'est la piste qui revient en force les
grandes fortunes vous le voyez son
pointée du doigt dans les cortège à
l'image de Bernard Arnault l'homme le
plus riche du monde aujourd'hui qui
cristallise les colères dans les
manifestations alors partage ou
reportage est-ce que c'est si simple que
ça marine Tondelier elle est pour vous
cette question vous dont les propos on
fait couler beaucoup d'encre sur les
milliardaires égoïstes vampires sans
talent évidemment on va y revenir ce
soir bonsoir Jean René Cazeneuve bonsoir
et merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance du Gers et le rapporteur
général du budget ici même à l'Assemblée
nationale bonsoir Béatrice Mathieu
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous venez de
signer une double page dans votre
hebdomadaire qui passe au Crips
justement les alternatives au recul de
l'âge légal et qui inspiré ce débat ce
soir bonsoir François girolles bonsoir
ravi de vous retrouver vous êtes
économiste à l'OFCE on a besoin de
connaître le vrai du faux parmi toutes
ces pistes qu'est-ce qui peut marcher
qu'est-ce qui est finançable ou pas
enfin bonsoir Gérard mardinet bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes le secrétaire
général de la CFE-CGC syndicat des
cadres opposés à cette réforme et bien
vous nous direz ce que vous proposez
pour
garantir le système à la place du
reportage on commence comme chaque soir
par le biais de la Coupe si j'ai bien
compris les riches sont une obsession
française alors serait-il suffisant de
les imposer pour régler tous les
problèmes en particulier celui des
retraites le chrono de la côte tout de
suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous d'accueillir bonsoir Stéphane
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous Alors
sur ce débat sur les riches vous allez
donc débattre des différentes méthodes
pour financer le système d'air très bon
on peut peut-être commencer par la
méthode qui a la préférence des Français
elle est en tête dans les sondages
regardez 80% de presque des Français
pensent qu'il faudrait accélérer riches
pour financer le système bon c'est pas
exactement formuler comme Instagram
laupes mais ce qui est frappant c'est
que tout le monde en fait est d'accord
évidemment regardez chez ELV bravo vous
êtes les premiers
à 6% de vos sympathies qui disent que
non on va pas les taxer mais même si les
républicains qui sont pas vraiment
favorables valider il y a quand même une
majorité de sympathisants qui disent oui
il faut taxer il y a pas que les
Français qui dit ça dans leur coin c'est
cette idée de t'accélérer c'est des gens
très spectacles qui disent ça donc
prenons quatre articles publiés dans les
échos regardez c'était un des meilleurs
journaux français c'est le plus cher en
tout cas 3,40 le numéro c'est la
propriété de Bernard l'homme le plus
riche du monde et voilà ce qu'on lit
dans les échos que le FMI voudrait
accéder plus riches donc le FMI
fondateur international la BCE la Banque
centrale européenne elle veut accéder
plus riche l'Espagne elle a déjà taxé
les riches Joe Biden lui aussi ça le
chiffonnerait ça le dérangerait pas que
c'est notamment les pétroliers donc là
on pense à notre fleuron français
évidemment total 20 milliards de
bénéfices et l'an dernier parler d'une
tuile pour Patrick Pollionnay ça il est
très emmerdé Patrick bouyenne parce que
lui il était bien dans sa tour au sommet
il disait bonjour à personne tout allait
bien et là tu es obligé d'aller se
justifier dans la presse franchement il
a que ça à faire regardez elle est dans
parisien dire mais écoutez c'est pas
grave il y aura peut-être une autre
ristourne si l'essence commence à
augmenter regarde il est tellement
embêté avec tous ces milliards je sais
pas quoi en faire il a dit ça dans le
Figaro il a dit je préférerais que Total
gagne 10 milliards de moins plutôt que
tous ces malentendus avec les Français
alors ça c'est quand même touchant un
comme dit Jules Renard si l'argent
ne fait pas le bonheur
il y a eu un truc comme ça Davos il y a
200 millionnaires qu'ils ont dit mais
faudrait plus t'accélérer les riches
d'ailleurs j'imagine que Marine tondelei
et les a applaudis malheureusement ils
avaient que deux Français parmi ces 200
millionnaires heureusement rassurez-vous
Bruno Le Maire est là et il a tendu la
main ou 198 autres il est prêt à les
accueillir en écoute
s'ils veulent s'installer en France ils
sont les bienvenus ils ont droit au taux
d'imposition parmi les plus élevés de
tous les pays développés donc que vous
serez d'une des personnes les plus
taxées au monde et donc vous serez
heureux donc venez en France croyez moi
nous serons vous taxés et les blagues de
Bretagne moi j'aime bien enfin après je
sais pas si ça fait tout le monde
regarde pour ce qui est Patrick pour y
aller vous voyez il y a une solution
pour ces 10 milliards en trop il fait un
virement à l'ordre du Trésor public je
pense que Bruno maire ne fera aucun
problème pour l'encaisser mais l'un des
meilleurs malgré tout arguments pour
t'accélérer riches ce sont toutes celui
de Joseph stiglinski étant prix Nobel de
l'économie forcément c'est un petit peu
de crédit ce qu'il dit donc il dit qu'il
faudrait taxer à 70% donc il parle des
revenus mais aussi les patrimoine autant
de 2-3% donc Oxfam a fait le calcul pour
la France on a 42 milliardaires sur les
taxes à 2% sur leur patrimoine c'est
genre 12 milliards par an entre à peu
près l'équivalent du déficit attendu en
2027 on pourrait taxer toutes les uns à
2% pour équilibrer notre donc c'est pas
vraiment ce que dit ça il y a une autre
énigme pour sport retraite il dit ça
serait sans doute la meilleure manière
de garder la cohésion dans nos sociétés
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a un peu
menacé par le populisme la colère gronde
on montre et on désigne des boucs
émissaires est accéléré faire revenir un
peu la paix parce que quand il s'agit de
faire monter la colère contre les riches
je veux dire qu'il y en a qui savent
faire on écoute le meilleur d'entre eux
il est là
voilà bah c'est peut-être une mode pas
une mauvaise idée de t'accélérer
justement pour apaiser un peu cette
colère parce que quand on traite les
riches de vampires qu'est-ce qu'on fait
après on leur plante un peu dans le cœur
quand on dit après parasite on fait quoi
c'est des nuisibles il faut les éliminer
il faut aller attention hein ça va aller
merci merci beaucoup pour ce regard
comme comme chaque soir piquante de
Stéphane je commence avec vous marine
tondeuse on va venir sur vos propos dans
un deuxième temps mais d'abord c'est
c'est vrai que vous allez travailler
avec Cécile Duflot qui est à la tête
d'Oxfam aujourd'hui et qui nous dit 2%
2% sur les 42 plus grandes fortunes de
France ça permet de financer les
retraites est-ce que c'est aussi simple
que ça franchement c'est jamais simple
mais vous voyez quand le gouvernement a
décidé d'enlever 5 euros d'aide au
logement à toutes les tous les
bénéficiaires de l'appel en France
t'effacent non plus mais là ça leur
paraissait normal de le faire et donc
moi ce que je dis juste c'est que si ça
paraît simple de réformer la location
chômage pour envoyer plein beaucoup de
bénéficiaires dans la dans la
paupérisation si c'est logique de
raboter les aides au logement alors
pourquoi ne serait-il pas logique de
discuter de mettre sur la table au sujet
des partages avec des richesses surtout
sur cette réforme des retraites dont
plus beaucoup de monde s'accordent à
dire qu'elle n'était
urgente ni nécessaire et qui est quand
même beaucoup d'autres priorités dans la
séquence c'est une chose de mal sur la
table dans le débat si on a une autre de
dire voilà un plan B c'est à dire 2% sur
les 42 milliards d'air français chaque
année ça ramènerait d'après Oxfam 12
milliards par an et donc on travaille
pas tous deux ans de plus ça vous le
défendez mais oui parce qu'en fait on
veut nous faire croire qu'il y aurait
que deux alternatives soit travailler
plus longtemps soit avoir des pensions
moins élevées et on oublie toujours la
troisième variable possible c'est-à-dire
trouver de l'argent par des cotisations
patronales alors c'est sûr qu'il faut
pas le faire sur tout le monde pareil
qu'il faut prendre en compte les équipes
économiques l'emploi etc mais
manifestement il y a des gens dans ce
pays qui vivent très bien très très bien
et par ailleurs qui qui capte l'argent
grâce au service public grâce à nos
routes grâce à nos écoles grâce à nos à
hôpitaux c'est aussi parce que leur
entreprise soit en France que ça marche
et ce serait normal qu'il contribue on
sait que quand on accumule autant
d'argent en général c'est pas juste par
son propre murite et par son propre
talent ce serait de la justice une forme
de justice genre une occasion vous allez
nous dire votre avis sur la proposition
de Oxfam mais il y a quand même un
problème de concentration donc des
richesses dans notre pays quand on
regarde sur les 10 dernières années
alors tous les milliardaires se sont
enrichis sur le covid et même dans le
temps mais quand on regarde sur les 10
dernières années plus 439%
d'augmentation en 10 ans c'est c'était
essentiellement lié à l'essor du luxe il
faut s'en féliciter c'est un rapport
d'UBS est-ce que c'est pas un problème
tout de même réel en France on peut
parler sur le sujet donc je parlerai
évidemment que volontiers de la
répartition des richesses un réfugiés
de remarques prémières la première c'est
que je suis assez content qu'on est
enfin reconnu qu'il y avait un problème
de déficit pour les retraites donc
maintenant parce que on nous a
pendant deux mois trois mois sur il y a
pas de problème même on peut aller
jusqu'à 60 ans bon maintenant ça y est
on a reconnu
je trouve qu'on a progressé et c'est
tant mieux parce que c'est absolument
incontestable c'est bon dans les
solutions alternatives dont vous parlez
certaines
remettent en question notre système par
répartition et je trouve c'est assez
grave on a un système qui jusqu'à
présent fait que ce sont les actifs qui
payent pour les qui payent pour les
retraités et pas l'imposition donc on
est en train de casser ce principe et
moi je moi je suis très attaché à ce
système de répartition et on dit ben
écoutez c'est simple moins de solidarité
plus d'impôts mais ça c'est votre
argument général sur la répétition
qu'est-ce que vous pensez c'est 2% ou
deux ans qui voulait remettre en cause
la répartition il y a pas si longtemps
que ça hein
sur le sur le si vous voulez on est en
train de dire c'est peut-être ce qu'il
faut faire mais il faut se dire entre
nous que c'est la fin du système par
répartition et qu'on va augmenter les
impôts en France après
sur la proposition d'Oxfam pour vous
elle est tenable ou pas
elle est pas tenable donc je crois que
d'abord on a en France si vous voulez
quand vous prenez effectivement les
déclarations des uns et des autres au
niveau mondial elle est tas de pays où
l'imposition est bien inférieur à ce
qu'elle est en France et donc les marges
de manœuvre pour augmenter que ce soit
sur les entreprises ou que ce soit sur
les sur les particuliers et n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
en France tout le monde sait qu'on est
un niveau de prélèvement obligatoire et
taxation en France parmi les plus élevés
donc les 2% si on les mettait en place
immédiatement ces grandes fortunes
choisiraient l'exil fiscal et
partiraient je n'en sais rien si vous
l'aimez la fortune de Bernard Arnault
qui effectivement l'homme le coach c'est
son entreprise c'est pas il a pas de
l'argent il y a certainement beaucoup
d'argent à la banque c'est d'abord son
entreprise et donc notre philosophie à
nous c'est de c'est d'aider les
entreprises peut-être faire en sorte que
qu'on aille vers le plein emploi la plus
grande inégalité c'est le chômage la
plus grande inégalité c'est le RSA et
moi je suis très fier d'appartenir à une
majorité qui depuis 2017 fait baisser le
chômage et fait baisser le nombre
d'allocataires du RSA et ça ça veut dire
soutenir notre économie François
girolles le regard de l'économie sur ce
rapport d'oxam c'est un gros rapport qui
a été publié au moment de Davos mais qui
va dans le détail proposer ces 2% sur
les 42 milliardaires c'est de la
démagogie ou il y a peut-être chaque
année avec 2 % les moyens d'éviter les
deux ans de plus de travail pour les
Français non alors comme vous l'avez
rappelé il y a un certain nombre de gens
qui disent qu'il y aurait des raisons
pour augmenter les impôts sur les plus
riches le FMI la Banque centrale
européenne c'est pas des gens qui sont
considérés comme des gauchistes
exactement
de lier ce débat celui des retraites et
là je suis un petit peu plus mal à
l'aise mais c'est peut-être en partie de
la faute du gouvernement qui a présenté
la réforme des retraites comme ayant un
objectif principalement budgétaire c'est
parce que si cette question des
ultra-riches elle est dans tous les
cortèges et c'est très frappant de voir
les effigies de milliardaires il y a il
y a une cristallisation aussi de la
colère sociale avec
uniquement ce serait pas forcément le
plus opportun de taxer 2% sur une une
richesse
moi je vous avoue que je crois pas du
tout à la théorie du ruissellement je
crois pas du tout que l'ISF était
vraiment un gros problème pour
l'investissement dans le même temps je
pense pas que le remède résoudra tous
les problèmes de la France et je pense
que c'est une source de financement qui
est utile potentiellement mais c'est pas
non plus voyez c'est pas de ça qu'on va
obtenir tout le salut de la France donc
je pense en fait ni l'un ni l'autre là
je pense pas que la flat tax l'ISF etc
sont vraiment quelque chose qui vont
faire revenir l'investissement en France
je pense qu'il faut faire d'autres
choses de la même façon la baisse des
impôts de production je suis pas sûr que
ça va avoir l'impact escompté et donc
voilà je suis un petit peu mal à l'aise
par rapport à tout ça Béatrice Mathieu
sur cette question de la taxation des
riches elle revient en permanence elle
est sur cette question moi je voudrais
juste rebondir sur la présentation qui a
été faite auparavant il y a
une sorte de gloubi-boulga c'est la
ratatouille alors soit on alors on
mélange on taxe est super profit on taxe
les Ultra riches en tachent le rôle on
parlait des revenus non mais dans la non
je parle de la présentation qui a été
fait tout à l'heure il y avait il y a à
la fois taxé des super profites
d'accéder aux revenus t'accéder
patrimoine il y a un moment où il va
bien falloir atterrissent nous voilà
l'éclairage pour bien comprendre donc si
on revient sur là vous me parliez
d'Oxfam donc taxer le patrimoine c'était
bien ça c'était donc absolument on n'est
pas sûr on n'est pas sûr la taxation des
super des entreprises elles-mêmes donc
c'était donc je vois pas pourquoi on
parlait de Total parce que là c'était un
autre sujet voilà parce que les
bénéfices de Total ont été publiés hier
et que ces symbolique je suis tout à
fait d'accord ça n'est pas pareil c'est
les profits d'une entreprise ou de taxer
les revenus alors de ces dirigeants et
on revient sur la taxation là du
patrimoine
des
ultra riches je pense que
effectivement il y a une sorte de
dévoiement du régime par répartition un
petit peu pure qui est qui était qui
était fait il y a d'autres leviers et on
regardera c'est pas parce que l'opinion
poussé par un vent un peu je pourrais
même dire un peu populiste de la taxe
riche en fait ça sert à tout c'est à
dire ça sert à financer les retraites ça
sert le climat
la justice l'éducation
si on la mettait en place immédiatement
les investissements s'en vont l'emploi
l'emploi diminue non pas forcément non
pas forcément mais on aurait sans doute
peut-être qu'à l'horizon de 10-15 ans
sans doute peut-être moins d'ultra riche
ou en tout cas avec des mécanismes de
d'optimiser d'optimisation fiscale ils
auraient mis leur truc au Luxembourg ou
en Suisse mais c'est demain si vous la
mettez demain effectivement en septembre
Bernard Arnault sera toujours là est-ce
qu'il sait est-ce que c'est descendants
seront là dans 10 ans je peux pas le
dire et donc je trouve que c'est donc
pour vous on fait du simplisme politique
et c'est la mesure simpliste alors
Gérard maldiner votre regard sur ces
questions de partage de la richesse
partage de la valeur et puis on
regardera les autres pistes juste après
alors nous voilà on est très attaché à
remédier aux causes des
dysfonctionnements de notre système
économique qui se traduit sur notre
système de retraite alors d'abord je
vais rapporter la contradiction à
Monsieur Cazeneuve parce que notre
système de retraite aujourd'hui il est
en excédent pour les années en cours
2022 y compris et les projections que
fait le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites ne sont que des scénarios
basés sur des hypothèses les hypothèses
sur l'espérance de vie sont trop
optimistes un spécialiste économiques
assez optimistes il y a quand même un
déficit ça leur rapport du corps le
montre si vous prenez
des hypothèses existe en termes de
d'espérance de vie et bien non si vous
prenez des mesures sur l'emploi des
seniors qui se traduirait par un réel
apport de masse salariale et de
cotisation bien non ça ramènerait des
dizaines de milliards d'euros sur les
nous on a fait les calculs dans l'emploi
ça prend du temps non ça prend pas de
temps il suffit de prendre des mesures
législatives avec une Condat une
conditionnalité des êtres d'État par
exemple pour dire ben non il faudra que
les seniors restent dans l'emploi alors
toujours la même chose sur
l'interprétation de du rapport du corps
franchement je pensais qu'on allait
progressé on recule de d'un siècle non
mais franchement vous prenez le rapport
du corps dans tous les scénarios tous
pendant 25 ans 25 ans on est en déficit
à partir avec le seul attendez avec le
seul scénario les trois autres scénarios
on est en déficit à perpète jusqu'en sur
toute la période qui est regardée par
donc le scénario le plus favorable on le
déficit toujours que 25 ans et je vais
vous donner deux chiffres qui
sous-tendent ce scénario parce que vous
regardez le corps faut le dire
précisément il dit 1% 1,6% de croissance
de productivité par an ce qu'on n'a pas
fait depuis 20 ans la productivité quand
j'entends les écologistes dire non non
le PIB il faut pas qu'il croit il faut
reconnaître une croissance douce etc
vous imaginez la pression que ça met sur
toutes les PIB
avec des prévisions très favorable sans
de chômage 4,5% de chômage c'est ça
l'hypothèse du corps pour arriver
simplement un déficit pendant 25 ans
que vous pourriez faire tout le débat
là-dessus mais c'est pas notre angle
donc on va revenir à l'instant à notre
angle on va voir les différentes pistes
des différents pouvez proposer dans un
instant mais quand même ce que vous avez
dit on a besoin d'une petite explication
marine Tondelier c'était au meeting
unitaire de la nuque sur les retraites
nous revendiquons que nous ne voulons
plus en France 2 milliardaires nous nous
voulons une France 100 milliardaire ce
ne sont pas des talents ce sont des
vampires ce ne sont pas des génies ce
sont des égoïstes marine Tondelier alors
à ce moment-là on vous découvre en fait
un peu vénère ce soir cette phrase
personne ne vous connaît le grand public
ne vous connaît pas c'est pour sortir de
l'anonymat que vous avez dit ça j'ai dit
ça parce que le gouvernement nous a
proposé une réforme sur les retraites en
nous proposant d'abord une réforme de
justice disait-il et on voit bien des
débats qu'on a depuis tout à l'heure et
dans la rue depuis quelques semaines
c'est immoral d'être milliardaire de
justice après ils ont dit en fait c'est
une réforme d'effort et ben moi je veux
bien qu'on parle de vampires
mais il se trouve que c'est une réforme
qui pèse uniquement chez les personnes
qui ne travaillaient pas encore jusque
64 ans c'est à dire les non-cadre c'est
à dire toujours les plus précaires et
donc je trouve logique qu'on renvoie
aussi la
quand on accumule autant de richesse
c'est soit par l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles vous voyez
monsieur pouyanet total tout à l'heure
soit par l'exploitation de femmes
d'hommes et parfois même d'enfants et en
général par tout ça en même temps et
donc on parle parfois de de mérite 80%
des milliardaires français sont des
héritiers ont irrité de cette fortune on
parle parfois de talents mais Monsieur
Bernard Arnault qui a multiplié sa
fortune par trois depuis le début de la
crise covid n'a pas multiplié son talent
et ses efforts par trois son entreprise
a été étudiée par trois
je voudrais juste refaire je voudrais
pas défendre LVMH mais vous le ferez
très bien non non je serais très très
gênée mais quand on entend dans votre
bouche LVMH qui exploite les femmes les
enfants et les industrie du luxe
excusez-moi l'industrie du luxe
l'industrie des énergies fossiles ce ne
sont pas des industries qui sont bonnes
ni pour la justice ni pour
l'environnement je pense que
l'exploitation des enfants chez LVMH je
suis pas sûr vous me parleriez pas
parler LVMH en particulier
Arnault c'est 179 milliards d'euros de
fortune si un français avec gagné le
jour de l'Armistice le 11 novembre 1918
le gros loto de millions d'euros et
qu'il avait regagné tous les jours le
gros loto 37000 fois de suite c'est à
dire jusqu'à aujourd'hui voulez-vous
figurer l'ampleur de cette mortalité on
se rend même pas compte tellement c'est
de l'argent est-ce que ça le rend plus
heureux je n'en suis pas sûr ce qui est
sûr par contre c'est que plus on est
riche plus on émet de CO2 et plus on est
climaticide le supérieures de Bernard
Arnault je vous parle même pas de son
jet vous dit j'en ai besoin pour
travailler je vous parle de son
supérieur où il passe ses vacances et
met en un mois au temps de CO2 que un
Français moyen allez 125 ans chacun
pour financer les retraites quels sont
les autres pistes je le disais augmenter
légèrement les cotisations on va y
revenir augmenter le taux d'emploi des
seniors c'est ce que vous nous disiez
monsieur mardinet ou mettre à son
distribution les retraités
première piste relever le montant des
cotisations sociales ces cotisations
qu'un salarié payent tous les mois sur
son salaire pour financer les retraites
l'idée défendue par de nombreux
syndicats et certains économistes en
gros pour que vous ayez un ordre d'idée
il faudrait que qui est 4 euros par mois
de plus de cotisations c'est pas énorme
en plus hein que chaque salarié ou
chaque employeur
serait réparti sur tous les actifs sur
27 millions de personnes alors
qu'aujourd'hui avec la réforme proposée
par le gouvernement l'effort est surtout
demandé aux 6 millions de personnes qui
partent à la retraite d'ici 2030
deuxième piste ce serait d'augmenter le
taux d'emploi des seniors
qui le disent il suffit de revaloriser
remonter le taux d'emploi des seniors à
45%, et vous avez le complément du
déficit autre piste faire contribuer les
retraités eux vraiment des indexant leur
pension sur l'inflation aujourd'hui les
retraites suivent obligatoirement la
hausse des prix c'est la loi alors en
pleine inflation l'addition pour les
caisses de retraite et salées une idée
qui n'est pas du tout exploré par la
classe politique enfin dernière piste
ajoutez une dose de capitalisation cette
alternative ne s'est pas invité dans le
débat actuel car la classe politique est
attachée au système de répartition mais
pour certains économistes plutôt
libéraux ce pourrait être une solution
il s'agirait de cotiser pour sa propre
retraite en créant par exemple un fond
de pension à la française en plaçant de
façon obligatoire une partie des
cotisations pour la retraite
complémentaire
je vous propose de commencer par la
question des retraités et pourquoi ne
pas leur demander une petite
contribution Béatrice Mathieu en
désindexant les pensions de retraite de
l'inflation alors ça peut pas ça peut ne
pas être une désindexation totale on
peut imaginer que ce soit j'ai assez les
réformes c'est 50 nuances de réformes on
n'est pas obligé de faire tout ou voilà
et donc il y a des calculs qui ont été
faits que si on augmentait en fait que
si les pensions augmentaient un point de
moins que le taux d'inflation et bien
déjà on aurait résolu quasiment 40% en
fait du déficit qui est prévu à 2027
c'est une mesure parmi d'autres sachant
que aujourd'hui quand même que les
retraités aujourd'hui en moyenne mieux
que les actifs voilà en moyenne et ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas des
retraités pauvres évidemment il y a des
retraités pauvres évidemment mais en
moyenne encore une fois le patrimoine
d'une part des retraités supérieurs ou
patrimoine des actifs en moyenne le taux
de pauvreté des retraités est
supérieures au taux de pauvreté des
actifs et inférieur et à fonctionner
celui des jeunes donc on a une situation
comme alors vous allez répondre j'aurais
l'impression que et largement voilà
explorable d'après vous François
girolles je sais pas si elle explorer
parce qu'il faut rappeler que la
majorité a essayé quand même au début du
dernier quinquennat notamment avec une
hausse politique personne
voilà
exactement donc il y avait eu une
rébellion sur les CSG au départ la CSG
devait augmenter sur un gros ensemble de
la population ensuite on a décidé de le
mettre seulement au-dessus de 2000 euros
enfin il y a eu beaucoup de discussions
la majorité déjà eu du mal à mettre à
contribution les retraités une raison
électorale et politique on n'arrive pas
alors que c'est la raison quand on est à
la retraite on a presque plus rien à
payer je parle des grandes masses
exactement et il faut inclure dans le
niveau de vie des le fait qu'ils sont
plus souvent propriétaires de leur
logement et que donc en général le loyer
n'est plus une charge pour eux si on
prend ça si on prend ça en compte
effectivement leur revenu est supérieur
de 8% à celui de l'ensemble de la
population
on a on a testé et on a payé pour voir
si vous permettez l'expression et les
mêmes qui nous disent on dit voilà c'est
une bonne piste etc on en 5 ans nous ont
dit à longueur d'intervention dans
l'hémicycle vous avez baissé les
retraites vous avez laissé oui donc non
mais je l'ai entendu 250 fois les mêmes
qui aujourd'hui me disent mais tiens ce
serait bon donc
en même temps
l'idée d'aller contrôler les rentes
sachez quand même que une des raisons
pour lesquelles il y a pas un dérapage
total de nos retraites dans les
prochaines années c'est que on a des
sens simplement sur l'inflation et pas
sur l'augmentation des salaires le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités va
rapprocher de 20 points donc ce que vous
décrivez aujourd'hui Keta c'est juste
c'est à dire que le niveau de vie
aujourd'hui et on est un des rares pays
d'un retraité et
équivalent voir légèrement supérieur à
celui d'un actif et on peut se poser la
question effectivement est-ce que c'est
juste ou pas et simplement en indexant
que sur l'inflation mais pas sur les
salaires en quelques années on va on va
perdre 20 points de pouvoir donc
attention est-ce qu'on veut empirer
cette situation dans une situation notre
mesure nous c'est d'augmenter les
petites retraites à la CGC il regarde
pas trop bien j'imagine les retraités
qui verraient leur potion baisser un
petit peu c'est ça en plus tout ça c'est
des chiffres moyens or la moyenne c'est
personne il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont à la retraite avec des retraites
petit ou moyennes et qui sont locataires
et qui eux
ont du mal à avec leur retraite je
voudrais quand même revenir sur
l'équilibre parce que s'il y a dans les
projections à venir une augmentation des
dépenses c'est parce que la bosse du
pepy-boom démographique du Peppy boom
donc arrive et qu'il va y avoir plus de
retraités mais faut rappeler que pour
les retraites des salariés du privé qui
sont bien gérés et pour beaucoup de
régimes spéciaux il y a aujourd'hui 180
milliards d'euros de réserves pour y
faire face et ça ça doit être considéré
vous proposez on prend les réserves des
régimes spéciaux supprimés pour financer
les retraites des autres parce que si il
y a un problème de financement au niveau
de des retraites c'est au niveau des
retraites des fonctionnaires parce que
l'État a géré de manière totalement
absurde la retraite des fonctionnaires
pourquoi parce qu'il n'embauche plus de
fonctionnaires au statut donc il y a
moins d'actifs pour beaucoup de
retraités
et pas de demander à tous nos
concitoyens de travailler plus longtemps
mais de monopoliser toutes ces
ressources y compris en allant lutter
contre l'afrod et l'évasion fiscale qui
représente 80 milliards par an je
voudrais qu'on avance il y a la piste
défendue par Laurent Berger très
clairement zéro virgule point de
cotisation en plus d'ici 2027 ça ça
permettrait d'éviter de travailler deux
ans de plus oui mais les
cette façon là oui ça permet de
rapporter une dizaine de milliards de 12
milliards d'euros en 2027 c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut trouver voilà
au niveau du SMIC ça doit être 14 euros
par mois quelque chose comme ça au
niveau du salaire moyen 28
14 euros en moins pour smicard je cite
vos chiffres et 28 euros pour un salaire
moyen c'est pas indolore c'est pas
indolore dans un contexte justement où
on parle de de contraction du pouvoir
d'achat marine Tondelier moi j'ai juste
sur une chose là-dessus c'est que ce
système de retraite par répartition que
je soutiens fonctionne aussi parce que
les actifs cotisent en faisant un jour
j'aurais ma retraite et ce sera mon tour
et les actises quand ils sont dans un
moment de crise climatique où les
enfants qui naissent en 2023 on ne sait
pas leur garantir l'habitabilité de la
planète pendant 30 ans moi j'ai 36 ans
je ne sais pas si j'aurais une retraite
un jour parce que je pense qu'au moment
de l'effondrement le système de retraite
n'est pas le dernier truc qui survit et
que à plus 4 degrés on sera pas en train
de se parler de repartition de
capitalisation de 72 ou 64 ans et du
coup je pense que si on veut que ce
système fonctionne que la confiance
tienne dans ce système de retraite par
répartition c'est bien de manifester
dans la rue c'est bien d'avoir des
propositions mais aussi falloir
s'occuper du climat parce que je pense
que la confiance mutuelle qu'on met dans
système et donc dans l'avenir un système
de retraite par répartition c'est une
confiance dans l'avenir et pour les
jeunes générations et je suis déjà un
peu vieille pour la jeune génération
j'ai conscience de ça en disant et un
peu en train de s'effondrer on arrive à
la limite de cette confiance là c'est
moi aussi ma crainte pour les retraites
à l'avenir genre René Cazeneuve c'est la
ligne rouge on augmente jamais les
impôts donc surtout pas les cotisations
c'est clairement une option ça n'est pas
la nôtre parce que effectivement 400
euros de moins par an pour l'ensemble
des salariés en France quand on le dit à
juste titre peut-être que 5 euros c'est
la fin du monde et que quand on supprime
les APL on est à 5 euros près si on
enlève 400 euros à tout le monde dans
une période de crise du pouvoir d'achat
je pense que ça n'est pas le moment
parlait pas
[Musique]
on améliore peut-être le taux de chômage
mais le halo du chômage c'est à dire
tous les gens qui ne sont pas demandeurs
d'emploi le halo du chômage ne diminue
pas ça c'est dans les statistiques de
l'INSEE et en plus il y a tous les
emplois précaires les travailleurs des
plateformes etc qui eux que cotisent
très peu pour la retraite finalement et
donc finance très peu le système et
demain seront rattrapés par la
solidarité c'est bon il faut
restructurer notre économie on prend du
temps de réindustrialiser et de
retrouver de l'emploi industriel d'abord
il faut d'abord commencer si c'est une
priorité nationale par
instaurer une gouvernance responsable
des grandes entreprises qui vont donner
une priorité à investir pour être des
acteurs engagés de la transition
écologique et créer des emplois dans
notre pays a besoin pour retrouver notre
souveraineté plutôt que de distribuer
des dividendes à gogo un 80 milliards de
dividendes des rachats d'action l'an
dernier qui vont pour 40 milliards
d'euros la moitié financer les fonds de
pension de nos amis ang alors pour
boucler la boucle et ce sera le mot de
la fin j'en René Cazeneuve si vous ne
taxez pas les super riches avec la
question de du partage de la valeur il
va bien falloir un jour le faire se
partage de la valeur face aux dividendes
qui explose est-ce que vous pouvez nous
annoncer des choses non tout le monde
réfléchit aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a
des sujets d'inégalités et notre combat
c'est de réduire ses inégalités et on
réduit les inégalités avec cette réforme
des retraites on pense effectivement que
la réforme de partage de la valeur au
sein des entreprises avec la
participation avec tous ces tous ces
outils on doit aller beaucoup plus loin
encore exploitement il y aura j'espère
un steak de loi soit sur le sujet soit
dans le cadre du prochain PLF en tous
les cas on veut absolument aboutir sur
ce sujet et je partage votre objectif ce
que c'est ce que nous faisons maintenant
depuis un certain temps faire en sorte
que nous créons nous avons créé un
million 6 d'emplois depuis 5 ans les
investissements industriels enfin
reviennent en France c'est une partie de
la solution mais là c'est plutôt long
terme et il les entreprises si on va
arriver à ce résultat merci on va
s'arrêter là on voulait justement faire
le pari de balayer toutes les options
alternatives à cette réforme chacun ce
sera fait son opinion merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu débattre sur le
plateau de LCP vous restez avec moi de
lier dans une dizaine de minutes
maintenant nous affranchis pour les
parties prises vous les voyez ce soir
Nicole Ferroni nous fait l'honneur de
son billet sur les retraites on a hâte
de vous entendre il y aura Isabelle
Lasserre aussi qui rejoindra pour nous
raconter son interview exclusive de volo
du meilleur Hélène Skype Bourbon express
avec Marco pommier l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée mais d'abord on va parler de
vous les Français vous découvrent je le
disais marine Tondelier vous avez pris
les reines d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
il y a deux mois c'est un parti en mal
d'adhérent c'est un parti bousculé aussi
par l'affaire Julien Bayou est divisé
sur sa ligne politique bref tout État
reconstruire on voit cela après
l'invitation signée m'a été vraiment
si on vous invite marine Tondelier c'est
parce que vous la patronne des écolos
vous avez décidé de dépoussiérer Europe
Écologie Les Verts coups d'envoi ce
matin de vos états généraux 150 jours
pour refonder en profondeur votre
mouvement en commençant par un
changement de nom c'est pas là pour dire
est-ce qu'on est l'écologie féministes
et qu'on est environnementalistes on est
tout ça on est les écologistes et tous
celles et ceux qui veulent nous
qualifier veulent en fait nous diviser
donc on sera tout ça à la fois car votre
tâche est ardu marine ton de lier
dorénavant numéro une du parti écolo
votre mission est de fédérer une aile
droite représentée par Yannick Jadot et
une aile gauche incarnée par Sandrine
Rousseau oui on
environnementale oui nous devons le
faire allons-y le tout en pleine affaire
Julien Bayou votre prédécesseur quand un
peuple est mécontent se dirigeant ce
n'est pas le peuple qu'on change ce sont
les dirigeants et bien chez ELV nous
appliquons cette edage à notre partie
donc nous avons décidé de changer fille
du Nord vous avez été marine
tondeuillier conseillère municipal
conseillère régional puis candidate par
deux fois au législatives face à l'autre
marine d'hény Beaumont militait dans
l'adversité dites-vous ne vous effrayez
pas c'est un Front national je vous le
cache pas qui est difficile à combattre
parce que c'est un Front National qui
n'en dit pas le nom mais c'est pas le
Front national caricatural qui va faire
tout est provocations militante depuis
vos 22 ans ancienne collaboratrice
parlementaire de Cécile Duflot la
politique vous est familière mais
beaucoup vous découvrent l'Assemblée
nationale ça va être la ZAD
ce sens de la formule vous l'associer à
votre présence dans les manifestations
on n'a pas fini de prévoir vous voici
dans le carré de tête aux côtés des
figures de la gauche travail tous
ensemble et solidaire de ce mouvement
pour grossir les rangs de votre partie
qui compte aujourd'hui 12000 adhérents
vous avez marine tondeuillier et un
objectif atteindre un million de
sympathisants d'ici à 2027 un million la
marée haute mise alors une question ce
soir comment comptez-vous faire à
l'heure ou plus aucun parti politique ne
fait rêver
on est en 2023 il est parti politique ne
font plus rêver c'est pas un problème du
parti écologiste mais de tous les partis
c'est pour ça qu'on va créer un nouveau
mouvement un grand mouvement de
l'écologie enfin qui ne sera pas qu'un
mouvement de l'écologie politique qui
sera un mouvement qui s'adresse à toutes
celles et ceux que Bruno Latour qui a un
grand philosophe l'environnement
appelait la nouvelle société il nous a
quitté il y a 4 mois et il avait écrit
un livre il y a un an un mémo à
l'attention des dirigeants écologistes
qui disaient vous savez la classe
écologique elle est majoritaire dans ce
pays mais elle n'est pas consciente
d'elle-même elle n'est pas fière
d'elle-même elle n'est pas structurelle
n'est pas organisée alors qu'en fait ils
le sont vous êtes très ambitieuses
attirer un million de sympathisants en 5
ans il faut tout refonder du sol au
plafond imaginons que j'ai 20 ans que je
milite pour le climat à extinction
rébellion ou aux collectif just no hoy
moi les partis politiques ça m'intéresse
pas du tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
cause comment vous allez m'attirer et
bien c'est exactement pour ça qu'on a
appelé notre processus venez comme vous
êtes comme as you are de Nirvana pour
ceux qui ne préfèrent en anglais mais
vous voyez nous on veut s'adresser à
celles et en qui vit en bout d'écologie
qui soit lecteur d'un jour de toujours
ou qui votent plus que ce soit des
parents des grands-parents inquiets pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants ou des
amoureux de la vie sauvage ou des jeunes
écho anxieux toutes ces personnes
doivent pouvoir se retrouver quand on
préfère l'action des classes
enfin on vient de ces mouvements là et
vous savez il y a pas une ligne rouge
entre d'un côté les activistes de
l'autre côté les politiques on est tous
là à la fois et donc je pense que il
faut qu'on arrive à se construire ce
mouvement à l'image de toutes celles et
ceux qu'on cite depuis tout à l'heure et
donc du coup pas notre image à nous nous
on est déjà là et l'idée c'est du coup
de confier les clés du camion de se
mettre en risque dans un processus
vraiment très participatif très
démocratique où les gens vont venir dans
des ateliers de leur avis on a une
grande enquête en ligne ils pourront
déposer leurs doléances des messages
vidéos audio et à partir de tout ça on
va monter une grande convention
citoyenne pour façonner ensemble ce
nouveau mouvement qui ne vous
ressemblera pas à nous mais à celles et
ceux dont on veut qu'il ou elle vienne
ça se passe sur les écologistes.fr et
vous verrez qu'en 2027 nous serons
mignons donc ça c'est les intentions ça
va être joyeux la démocratie évidemment
voilà on a besoin en même temps c'est
vraiment la fracture qu'on a vu
notamment à la présidentielle chez
europécologie les Verts est-ce que vous
avez compris les raisons de votre échec
et bien évidemment sinon on serait pas
en train de tout réinventer moi 4 %.
c'est pas qu'un problème de Yannick
Jadot moi je le dis les échecs sont
collectifs je pense que le parti n'était
pas prêt on était 4000 adhérents en 2017
on avait perdu tous nos députés donc on
a fait la remontada aux européennes en
2019 au municipales en 2020 et personne
ne nous attendez là
compatibles entre celles de l'éco
féminisme radical de Sandrine Rousseau
et celle plus réformiste raisonnable de
Yannick Jadot est-ce qu'il y a pas
quelque chose de complètement
irréponible ah non j'aurais pu
totalement ça mais on veut fait des ré
les écologistes à commencer par celles
et ceux qui sont déjà dans l'autre
partie et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
je propose comme nom de mouvement les
écologistes parce que toutes celles et
ceux qui veulent nous qualifier mettre
un adjectif après par exemple l'écologie
et qu'au féministe écologie animaliste
l'écologie environnementaliste
l'écologie radicale ou pragmatique en
fait celles et ceux qui veulent faire ça
VE se mettre dans des cases donc nous
diviser donc nous affaiblir moi je
revendique d'être tout cela à la fois je
suis écologiste donc radical donc
pramatisme donc éco-féministe donc
animaliste dont environnementaliste on
est tout ça à la fois c'est ce que
j'appelle l'écologie indivisible et vous
parlez de conflit et dans le passé qui
était très regrettable moi qui m'abîme
de la violence même on l'a vu dans la
prise mais je pense que quand on dit du
mal d'un écologiste dans la presse alors
on dit du mal de l'écologie et ça
abîmait beaucoup de militants c'est ce
qui explique aussi le résultat du
congrès ou très massivement ils se sont
en prononcés pour siffler la fin de la
récré et je dois noter que depuis le
Congrès en fait on est plutôt occupé à
parler de fond on a parlé des
milliardaires des retraites de beaucoup
de choses de notre refondation et plus à
parler de querelle et interpersonnelles
nous sommes à l'offensive la nuque c'est
pour avoir un groupe à l'Assemblée quand
vous dites nul vous enlevez le et de
écologie ça nous fait mal au cœur alors
là les pince c'est pour avoir un gros à
l'Assemblée ou c'est pour avoir un
candidat commun en 2027
évidemment quand on fait l'accord au
législative c'est pour les législatives
pour la mandature là donc c'était la
raison initiale mais moi ça vous partez
déjà seul pour les européennes donc on a
l'impression que c'est un peu un
instrument uniquement pour être
européenne c'est différent le sujet sur
lesquels on n'est pas d'accord dans la
nups ou avec Jean-Luc mélench quelque
chose singulier d'une Europe forte et
fédérale on pense que c'est la solution
pour l'environnement mais moi vous savez
où je milite à une un moment dans le
Pas-de-Calais évidemment je suis
tétanisée comme plein de gens face à une
victoire possible de Marine Le Pen en
2027 et je pense que cette hypothèse et
chaque semaine plus probable pensait que
la colère sociale sur les retraites du
profit directement je les vois nulle
part en ce moment national donc je sais
pas où ils sont je sais pas ce qu'ils
font ils sont pas dans la rue ils sont
pas en train de d'essayer de mobiliser
et je sais pas à quoi ils servent dans
la séquence mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'en général dans ce pays quand les
gens sont en colère ça finit par leur
profiter mais ce que je vous dis juste
pour finir sur 2027 évidemment qu'il va
falloir travailler ensemble et
évidemment que le sujet d'une
candidature unique se pose mais ça ne
suffira pas ce sera une condition
nécessaire mais non suffisante et
pourquoi on fait ces états généraux de
l'écologie ce que j'appelle cultiver
votre jardin c'est parce que dans un
socle lui pèse électoral à 30%, ça ne
suffira pas on pourra être au deuxième
tour éventuellement mais moi je m'en
fous d'être au deuxième tour je le
congagne être au deuxième tour pour être
content ça ne sert à rien il y a
personne et vous voulez gagner on
comprend qu'on voulait vous dire qu'il
faut que chacun il faut que chacun
progresse si c'est mélangeons candidats
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
pour faire des candidats ça vous
convient ou ce sera non vous êtes chef
de partie aujourd'hui je pense très
sincèrement vous avez un avis là-dessus
bah oui mais déjà un je suis pas obligé
de vous le donner il l'est pas et
troisièmement on va discuter tous
ensemble mais pas en commençant par le
nom de la candidature évidemment que
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire pour
que ça marche un mot sur les retraites
après la dernière manifestation la CGT
pourrait durcir le mouvement avec des
blocages dans les raffineries notamment
vous qui soutenez le mouvement social on
a vu les images vous étiez dans les
cortèges parisiens est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut des actions plus dures
ou pas
mais la vie est dure ce mouvement social
il est joyeux pour l'instant et on passe
de très bons moments dans la rue c'est
un moment où après des humiliations
semaine après semaine on relève la tête
après l'humidité de son trop cette
réforme des retraites et ce qui se passe
là va pas s'arrêter jusqu'au bout
quand je vous dis que le blocage du pays
c'est que c'est fatigant de voir
toujours qu'on renvoie ça au
syndicaliste ou aux gens qui font le
mouvement social ceux qui sont durs en
ce moment c'est le gouvernement parce
que ils ont une mobilisation sociale
historique dans les dix dernières années
on n'avait jamais vu ça et que qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils ne bouge pas d'un yota
ils sont sourds à cette mobilisation et
quand le peuple est dans la rue je le
disais tout à l'heure dans le reportage
c'est pas le peuple qu'on change c'est
le gouvernement le mouvement
stradicalise vous serez aux côtés de et
vous savez
quand on dit gentiment
et que ils font semblant de ne pas
entendre alors oui on ne dit plus fort
on dit plus fort jusqu'où
ils ont enlevé 5 euros d'APL ils ont
cassé l'assurance chômage et aujourd'hui
ils veulent très faire travailler les
plus précaires deux ans de plus ils ont
supprimé des critères de pénibilité ça
c'était de la violence
au Parlement est-ce que vous respecterez
le vote
on est quand même des républicains mais
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que tout
de même y compris d'un point de vue
parlementaire c'est très violent ce qui
se passe tout est fait pour que le débat
est soit le plus court possible pour
qu'il n'est pas vraiment lieu donc oui
c'est une violence aussi démocratique et
je pense que les Françaises et les
Français sont pas dupe vraiment on a
commencé par expliquer que c'était une
réforme de justice et que c'est
l'opposition qui a dû faire le vous
savez parfois il faut démêler le vrai du
faux certains journalistes font ça des
désenfox c'est quand même l'opposition
qui a dû faire la désenfox des infos du
gouvernement ce serait réforme des
retraites dans un pays comme la France
c'est quand même inquiétant allez je
voudrais vous entendre sur la manière
avec laquelle Adrien Catena aujourd'hui
député non inscrits a repris la parole
on va voir les images c'était dans
l'hémicycle mardi soir applaudi vous le
foyer
une partie de ces anciens collègues
insoumis
voilà
chers évidemment pas plus à une partie
de la majorité qui s'est immédiatement
indigné Aurore Berger a trouvé cette
scène totalement indécente et vous
Robert berger n'est pas la dernière en
matière d'indécence ils avaient quand
même investi au législatif un candidat
qui avait collé 14 jours DTT à sa femme
c'est-à-dire l'ange conjugale très très
grave
évidemment que non évidemment que non et
j'ai quitté
et je me suis sentie un peu prise aussi
au piège j'imagine comme plein de
collègues sur ces bancs ou en fait on
est là pour parler des retraites c'est
un moment qui est important et puis on
se retrouve à devoir commenter le retour
d'Adrien Catena c'est pas notre urgence
du moment et puis on parle même pas de
ce qu'il a dit vous voyez là on vient de
reparler de lui on ne sait même pas il a
dit son opposition à la réforme il
l'harmonie d'ailleurs depuis on parle
même pas du fond c'est le sujet est
juste le retour d'Adrien Catena c'est
donc c'est bien la preuve que c'est un
sujet et pour moi il n'aurait pas dû
revenir dernière petite question sur
l'affaire Julien Bayou donc Sandrine
Rousseau a dit que si ça se reproduisait
le refray c'est à dire elle referait ses
accusations sur sur un plateau de
télévision comme elle l'avait fait en
direct dans cet à vous sur France 5
pourtant le parti a acté la fin de la
mise en retrait de Julien Baillou est-ce
que vous comprenez que Sandrine Rousseau
ne puisse pas reconnaître au fond que la
page est tournée qu'il est innocent vous
savez je suis une femme politique et
donc vous ne ferez jamais entrer en
opposition sur un sujet féministe avec
une féministe évidemment par contre ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que notre
partie dans la manière dont cette
affaire a pu être traitée en interne a
vraiment touché le la limite de notre
protocole enfin c'est un sujet qui était
tellement particulier qu'on s'est rendu
compte que y compris notre cellule on
est le premier parti à avoir mis en
place ce genre de choses parce que la
police et la justice ne traite mal ces
sujets et donc on a un grand audit qui
organisé à partir de février 2023 là
pour revoir notre procédure traiter
mieux ces sujets et je tiens à ce qu'on
ne parle pas juste de ne pas se faire
agresser et et volonté dans ce parti
évidemment moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on garantisse le bien-être
l'épanouissement des femmes c'est c'est
ça qu'on va travailler bien plus
largement qu'une cellule contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles on veut
être émancipateur accueillant et donc je
répète venez comme vous êtes sur les
écologistes.fr c'est dit merci beaucoup
marine ton délier vous restez avec nous
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris venez
venez venez les amis
Isabelle Lasserre qui a eu l'immense
privilège l'honneur même de pouvoir
rencontrer en personne qui pour son
journal de Figaro interview exclusive
elle va nous raconter ses impressions
sur l'homme sur ses attentes dans un
instant et bienvenue à vous Nicole
Ferroni merci bienvenue j'avais déjà
bienvenu Myriam vous êtes un peu chez
vous aussi on est ravis de vous
accueillir de temps en temps dans cette
émission votre regard sur la réforme des
retraites nous intéresse on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir par Marco pommier
bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam oui écoute
théâtre cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
depuis 15 heures la majorité
présidentielle et l'opposition
s'affrontent sur une proposition de loi
du groupe socialiste visant à protéger
le groupe EDF d'un éventuel démembrement
texte qui a tellement enflammé
l'hémicycle aux alentours de 18h et bien
la majorité présidentielle et c'est
assez rare pour le souligner a décidé de
quitter la séance
nous refusons de participer à ce qui est
un déshonneur pour l'assemblée nous
devons respecter notre construction dans
ces conditions la majorité
présidentielle refuse de continuer à
participer à sa débats qui ne sont
qu'une mascarade
qu'est-ce qui se passe là
ben voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe
exactement reprenons du début
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée c'était une
journée de niche parlementaire une
journée réservée au groupe d'opposition
pour promouvoir leur proposition de loi
ce jeudi c'était donc les socialiste les
socialistes qui fixaient l'ordre du jour
avec un gros sujet celui d'EDF vous le
savez l'État a décidé de reprendre 100%
du capital du géant de l'électricité
sauf que les socialistes soupçonnent le
gouvernement de ne pas avoir renoncé au
projet Hercule c'est-à-dire de vendre
les activités rentables d'EDF pour
garder les activités non rentables
écoutez Arthur de la porte
qu'on ne sait pas c'est l'État veut
derrière monter au capital pour mieux
vendre à la découpe et ça c'est la vraie
ambiguïté c'est en fait finalement le
flou c'est pas parce qu'on possède
EDF aujourd'hui que demain on n'a pas
envie de vendre EDF à la découpe donc
l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est de
faire en sorte de vraiment protéger
notre électricité notre souveraineté
énergétique dans un contexte où il faut
et on a besoin de DF pour assurer la
souveraineté énergétique dans un
contexte de transition énergétique
et dans ce débat un article de cette
proposition de loi ami donc le feu aux
poudres article qui prévoit un bouclier
tarifaire spécifique pour les très
petites entreprises touchées par la
hausse des prix de l'énergie notamment
les artisans boulangers c'est là que la
véritable bataille s'est engagée dans
l'hémicycle pour la majorité et bien cet
article il est contraire à la
Constitution à qui prévoit que les
députés ne peuvent pas aggraver une
charge financière pour l'État le
gouvernement estime le coût de la mesure
à 18 milliards d'euros écoutez
au panthéon de la mauvaise foi vous
aurez mes chers collègues une place
d'honneur une place d'honneur parce que
vous nous dites aujourd'hui à cet
amendement de constitue pas une charge
pour les finances publiques parce qu'il
ne coûte rien mais s'il ne coûte rien
c'est qu'il est inutile et c'est une
hypocrisie de plus dans votre défense
des petits commerçants et des artisans
parce que la vérité c'est que vous ne
voulez pas assumer vos votes et vous ne
voulez pas affiner
de cet article sur les tarifs
réglementés parce que vous savez qu'on
en a besoin et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui votre
boucle est tarifaire il ne fonctionne
pas
je précise que le député qu'on a vu à
l'instant c'était un député de la
majorité Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre
petit problème de santé donc face aux
risques et bien d'être mis en minorité à
part les oppositions et bien la majorité
a décidé de quitter l'hémicycle
l'article et la proposition de loi ont
été votées sans la majorité mais
attention c'est que le début du parcours
législatif parce que le texte doit
encore être inscrit maintenant à l'ordre
du jour du Sénat à faire à suivre et là
il peut être complètement détricoté
merci beaucoup Marco alors Isabelle on
veut tout savoir dans quel état d'esprit
vous l'avez trouvé votre meilleur
Zélande qui je rappelle que votre
interview a été publié hier dans le
Figaro et vous êtes rares journalistes
françaises à avoir rencontré oui alors
curieusement moi j'avais déjà rencontré
il y a un an et demi c'est-à-dire
quelques mois avant le début de la
guerre il a pas vraiment changé en fait
volodingski il a un petit peu de barbe
il a un petit peu aussi dans les dans
les yeux une lueur de une son regard est
devenu beaucoup plus grave en fait mais
sinon
[Musique]
sur lui parce que j'avais fait un
portrait à côté d'interview et ben
Emmanuel Macron parce que je trouvais
oui il venait d'arriver au pouvoir et il
avait la même jeunesse la même
intelligence enfin en tout cas c'était
quelqu'un de très intelligent et le même
dynamisme la même énergie et surtout
cette espèce de cette volonté de vouloir
absolument tout changer et tout réformer
très très rapidement donc et aujourd'hui
oui je crois qu'il ressemble il a
vraiment des accents churchilliens il a
un charisme absolument incroyable il
fait preuve d'un leadership complètement
dingue il assure emmener en fait tout
son pays toute son armée tout son peuple
derrière lui jusque là déjà au bout d'un
an enfin on pensait que en fait il ne
tiendrait pas quelques jours il a il a
choisi de rester et non pas de fuir
alors que les Américains proposaient de
l'extirper là aussi de Churchill en fait
cette vision quand même cet avenir de de
pour son pays il a il a la vraie
conviction d'être dans le sens de
l'histoire une vraie conviction que
[Musique]
surface entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
mais c'est une guerre qui engage toute
la sécurité du contenu européen et
l'ordre international c'est notre guerre
merci beaucoup le papier était sur le
web hier mais il est en version print
comme on dit en français dans le Figaro
de ce matin merci beaucoup Isabelle
carte blanche Nicole Ferroni retraite
oui oui je vais vous parler d'un sujet
dont on parle très peu en ce moment à
savoir la réforme des retraites alors je
sais que ceux qui me connaissent un peu
vont dire allez encore une hystérique et
ça sert à rien les hystériques et ben
pour une fois je suis d'accord notamment
dans le cadre de cette réforme ça ne
sert à rien d'être hystérique en
revanche qui peut être utile c'est non
pas d'être hystérique mais d'être
hystérectomiser voilà bénéficier alors
je sais que certains vont dire Nicole
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu brutal
comme proposition de subir une ablation
de l'utérus alors oui mais bon moi je
pense que à réforme musclé on peut
peut-être aussi proposer des solutions
musclées et donc je vais vous expliquer
en quoi vous faire amputer l'utérus peut
être une bonne idée dans le cadre de
cette réforme comme vous l'avez sûrement
entendu le gouvernement souhaite
réhaussée le montant des petites
retraites jusqu'à 1200 euros alors pour
être précis c'est pas le minimum
vieillesse hein mais bien la pension de
retraite des salaires modestes aussi
appelé le minimum contributif qui
pourrait être donc porté jusqu'à 1200
euros pour des carrières complètes et
c'est là que beaucoup de gens pourraient
se dire ah voilà quelque chose qui peut
avantager les femmes notamment les mères
puisque comme les femmes ont
automatiquement des trimestres validés
qui leur sont attribués par enfant pondu
elles ont plus de facilité à atteindre
une carrière complète et donc à
bénéficier de cette hausse voulue par le
gouvernement alors pour rappel je le
précise une femme valide 8 trimestres
par enfant absolument dans le dans le
privé en revanche dans le public c'est
seulement 4 seulement la moitié dans le
public parce que parce que les femmes du
public font des demi-bébés
je crois donc ça ça couche très vite ça
se nourrit très très non en fait je moi
non plus je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai
jamais compris cette injustice mais en
tout cas globalement pour les femmes on
pourrait se dire que voilà bah comme
chaque enfant elle valide des trimestres
elles vont avoir plus vite une carrière
complète et pour mieux bénéficier de
cette hausse alors que non attention
parce que certes pour toucher ce minimum
contributif il faut avoir validé un
certain nombre de trimestres voilà pour
pouvoir justifier des fameuses 43
annuités complètes ce que les maires
pourraient faire plus facilement mais
son montant à ce minime contributrice
contributif et calculer non pas
seulement par les trimestres validés
mais par les trimestres cotisés
c'est-à-dire travailler or les
trimestres de maternité ne sont pas des
trimestres cotisés et ça astuce
mnémotechnique pour se rappeler quand
j'allaite mon bébé je me le colle-t-il
mais je ne cotise pas voilà d'où le
désavantage certains à avoir des enfants
et donc à vouloir garder son utérus même
si je vous l'accorde l'utérus c'est
c'est comme la retraite on avait ni
prévu ni envie de se faire amputer mon
Dieu on s'arrête là c'était clair c'est
très clair voilà et là je suis désolé
marine Candelier mais non mais on aborde
ici un vrai sujet celui de l'impact de
cette réforme sur les femmes qui merci
de le faire il y a pas que les milliers
mais c'est vrai que sur les trimestres
voilà travailler seuls les trimestres
travaillés sont pris en compte pour ça
je crois pas que toutes les femmes l'ont
bien en revenant et surtout les femmes
du public parce que quatre tripes 4
trimestres au lieu le pire c'est qu'en
fait personne au lieu de 8 on entend
parler de cette réforme dans le privé
des trucs différents et on est je pense
que chaque femme dans ce pays a du mal à
concevoir l'impact de cette réforme sur
sur soi-même parce qu'on ne comprend
rien en fait et donc on sait pas se
projeter alors quelque chose me dit que
les droits familiaux ça va faire l'objet
d'un prochain texte de loi on
reviendrait nous faire une chronique
évidemment avec ce qu'on va les compter
maintenant ah bah oui vraiment on y
tient quand même allez merci merci
beaucoup marine Tondelier merci à vous
les amis Marco pommier Merci à VOUS
Isabelle et à très vite on se quitte sur
ça Nicole à bientôt j'espère revenez
quand vous voulez très belle soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre Gratien et
puis à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]